en 1865 mendel considerado el padre de
la genética moderna aparece con una
manera estructurada de pensar en estos
factores hereditarios que ahora llamamos
genes y a medida que avanzamos hacia los
años 1900 su trabajo fue redescubierto y
la gente comenzó a decir está bien vemos
como algunas de estas características
son transmitidas de manera un tanto
predecibles que nos permiten estructurar
todo esto pero cuál es el mecanismo
biológico para todo esto como son
codificados estos rasgos a nivel celular
oa nivel molecular y así en 1902 y
hablamos de esto en un vídeo anterior
volver y sharon vienen con la teoría
cromosómica que se basa en ver cómo los
cromosomas se separan y se aparean
durante la división celular y diciendo
los cromosomas parecen coincidir
bastante bien con lo que méndez
describió acerca de los factores
hereditarios y comenzamos a tener mucha
más evidencia de esto
morgan demostró que una mutación en el
color de los ojos de las moscas de la
fruta parece ser transmitida mediante el
cromosoma sexual x y él y su equipo
comenzaron a hacer mucho más trabajo con
moscas de la fruta para demostrar que
los cromosomas son la base donde estos
factores hereditarios se encuentran pero
entonces incluso dentro de los
cromosomas las personas no estaban
seguras de cuál era la molécula o el
conjunto de moléculas que realmente
codificaban estos rasgos hereditarios ya
que los cromosomas están compuestos de
proteínas y adn y al inicio se creía que
las proteínas eran los responsables de
esto ya que las proteínas son estas
moléculas complejas que parecía que
podrían codificar para estos rasgos
hereditarios mientras que el adn al
menos al inicio parecía ser una especie
de molécula aburrida y la gente asumía
que no había mucha diversidad en el adn
se creía que incluso en diferentes
especies la molécula de adn era
fundamentalmente la misma
así que en un inicio la gente estaba del
lado de las proteínas pero luego se
encontró cada vez más evidencia a favor
del adn esto comenzó con el experimento
de griffith donde él decía puedo tomar
esta cepa de bacterias in activadas por
calor y si las mezcló con estas otras
bacterias vivas de alguna manera hay un
principio de transformación que
transforma a las bacterias vivas en la
otra cepa la que había sido in activada
por calor luego vamos a 1944 donde el
ver y mccarthy mcleod son capaces de
demostrar que el principio de
transformación lo que estaba en la cepa
de bacterias in activadas por calor que
transformó a la cepa de bacterias vivas
fue probablemente adn y después tenemos
evidencia aún más concluyente de esto
con los experimentos de hershey chase y
tenemos un vídeo completo acerca de esto
donde dicen que es lo que los virus
inyectan a las bacterias para secuestrar
su maquinaria genética
y dicen no son proteínas es adn lo que
hace esto por lo que proporcionan
pruebas mucho más concluyentes a favor
del adn pero incluso en ese momento
nosotros como comunidad o como
civilización todavía no sabíamos cuál es
la estructura real del adn del mismo
modo no sabíamos cómo es que esta
estructura codificada todos estos
factores hereditarios y el trabajo
culmina con watson y crick pero su
trabajo fue dependiente de todas las
personas que he mencionado y muchas más
y una persona que debe recibir crédito
especial por conseguir un poco más de
evidencia a favor del adn y por ayudar a
watson y crick en realidad hay varias
personas pero en particular son charlas
y rosalind franklin a grow selling
franklin particularmente no se le da
tanto crédito como ella merece
charaf quien demostró que el adn en
realidad es más interesante de lo que la
gente creía se dio cuenta de que las
frecuencias de las bases nitrogenadas
las frecuencias de las bases
nitrogenadas de adenina guanina citosina
y timina en el adn varían entre especies
varían
/
y especies
y algo que de alguna manera está
codificando lo que hace que una especie
sea diferente de las demás especies
tendría que variar de una especie a otra
así que eso hace al adn muy interesante
y entonces la otra cosa de la que se dio
cuenta y esto fue clave para el trabajo
de watson y crick es que la frecuencia
de guanina es igual a la frecuencia de
citocinas en el adn y la frecuencia de
adenina es igual a la frecuencia de
timina en el adn y esto es un indicio de
que estos de alguna manera están
asociados entre sí que de alguna manera
están apareados entre sí y así llegamos
a principios de los años 50 tuvimos toda
esta evidencia de que el adn es la base
molecular esta carga con sus reglas
conocidas como la ley de cargas y
tenemos a rawson in franklin quien
trabajó con patrones de difracción de
rayos x irradiados a través de cristales
de
n iv que quiero decir con cristales de
adn un cristal está conformado por un
montón de moléculas organizadas en un
patrón regular así que un cristal de adn
se ve algo así aquí tenemos una molécula
de adn y otra molécula de adn y otra
molécula de adn y luego se hace pasar
unas de rayos-x a través de ellas y
tienen que ser rayos x ya que su
longitud de onda es suficientemente
pequeña como para capturar los detalles
a un nivel atómico así que se hace pasar
un haz de rayos x
y los rayos x se disfrazan y se captura
el patrón de difracción y dependiendo de
la estructura de las moléculas se
tendrán diferentes patrones de
difracción aquí está el patrón de
difracción famoso de rose link franklin
cuando ella vio este patrón
inmediatamente se dio cuenta de que
tenía señales que indicaban que se
trataba de una estructura helicoidal no
es sencillo descifrar este patrón si no
se es un experto el lector de patrones
de difracción de rayos x ya que esta no
es una imagen directa de la molécula de
adn pero ella ya sabía y de hecho la
comunidad científica ya sabía que este
patrón en forma de x era un indicador de
que se trataba de una estructura
helicoidal de algún tipo y ellos también
eran capaces de descifrar las otras
pistas que se encuentran aquí cuál es la
distancia entre moléculas diferentes e
incluso la separación entre las
diferentes vueltas de la estructura
helicoidal
ahora una vez más este patrón de
difracción no es una imagen directa y se
necesita mucha experiencia para poder
descifrar cómo es la estructura que
provocó la difracción de los rayos x
para formar el patrón que estamos viendo
y se deben de tomar patrones desde
múltiples ángulos diferentes para
conseguir una mejor comprensión de la
estructura de hecho hoy en día se tiene
equipos que a partir de un patrón de
difracción empiezan a construir las
nubes de electrones y forman la
estructura de la molécula que se está
analizando
así que roussel in franklin hizo un
trabajo muy minucioso y ella ya tenía
una idea ella ya sabía que se trataba de
una estructura helicoidal pero estaba
esperando a conseguir un poco más de
evidencia antes de publicar su trabajo y
al mismo tiempo watson y crick estaban
tratando de descubrir la estructura del
adn también y pudieron ver el trabajo de
franklin con la ayuda de maurice wilkins
quien trabajaba con franklin
y ellos fueron capaces de establecer que
no se trataba de una sola hélice sino de
una doble hélice y que se tenía estos
pares de bases que forman los peldaños
de la doble hélice y esto fue muy
interesante porque mostró como el adn
puede replicarse a sí mismo la forma en
que podía contener información y veremos
esto con mucho más detalle en vídeos
futuros la parte triste de esta historia
es que wilkins watson y crick ganaron un
premio nobel y franklin lamentablemente
murió muy joven y no está permitido
otorgar premios nobel póstumos ella
realmente se merecía un premio nobel
este trabajo que es considerado como uno
de los mayores descubrimientos de la
ciencia se basó en lo que roussel in
franklin hizo podría decirse que es y
watson y crick no hubieran tenido acceso
al trabajo de franklin ellos no hubieran
sido capaces de dilucidar la estructura
del adn y si ella se hubiera apegado a
lo que estaba haciendo sin que otras
personas se hubieran tenido
acceso a su trabajo posiblemente ella
habría sido capaz de llegar a la misma
conclusión que watson y crick por lo que
ella es una de las personas que a veces
la historia de la ciencia pasa por alto
pero esto no es para no dar crédito al
trabajo de watson y crick todavía había
una gran cantidad de saltos de fe o
saltos intuitivos podríamos llamarles
muy importantes que tenían que hacer
para llegar a esta estructura de doble
hélice
esta estructura anti paralela de doble
hélice donde las hélices van en
direcciones opuestas y se unen con las
bases nitrogenadas que se aparean unas
con otras y esto es un descubrimiento
muy muy muy importante a lo largo de la
mayor parte de la historia humana
sabíamos que los rasgos se transmiten de
padres a hijos pero parecía que estos
rasgos eran algo místico es decir sé que
mi risa es como la de mi madre pero cómo
es que eso se codifica en mi adn
y ahora podemos ver que un montón de lo
que consideramos en nosotros mismos que
nos hacen ser nosotros está codificado
en estas moléculas en estos pares de
bases por lo que es hermoso es increíble
es arrojar luz sobre uno de los mayores
misterios de lo que hace a los humanos
humanos de hecho de lo que hace a todas
las formas de vida ser lo que son